hello everyone and welcome back to the
clutch chess international we are
continuing the match jeffrey
young versus magnus carlsen after the
first uh first three games that magnus
won three to zero
uh from the next five games uh two were
won
by xiong and three were drawn and this
is game nine uh
i i decided to skip uh some of the games
as uh
i'm taking a little break after the
lindoris abbey rapid challenges that was
really exhausting and we had the magnus
invitational before that so now i'm
kind of limiting it to one video per day
maybe today i'm gonna do two but
uh you know until i decide otherwise do
expect only one video per day
and now uh we're continuing with game
nine and it's a very interesting game in
the previous video we had uh sacrificing
without attacking and here
uh we sort of have uh sorry we had
attacking without sacrificing and here
we sort of have attacking with
sacrificing but
uh you know you're gonna see what i'm
talking about so in this game xiung is
white and
he opens with e4 uh we have c5 by magnus
uh and now
knight to f3 uh we have d6 d4
so just a normal open silent we have c
capture sunday for knight captures and
now knight to f6 we have knight c3
and of course a6 the nidorf is on the
board
uh and the bishop to d3 here you can
play a lot of moves like uh
like every any move here you can pretty
much play bishop c4
bishop d3 you can play f3 you can play
h3 you can play h4
you can play rook g1 you can develop the
bishop you can play bishop to g5
so there are so many ways of course you
can play against the night or
uh and shion goes for bishop to d3 and
okay uh magnus
will find cattle the dark square bishop
so he wants to castle by
by going like this we have f3 uh
defending this e4 pawn
and since magnus will probably play
bishop g7 in castles uh xiong is
preparing bishop to e3 queen to d2 and
then use the
queen bishop battery to trade off the
dark square bishop
so bishop to g7 and now bishop to e3
we have knight the c6 and the queen to
d2 now
we have this idea that we've mentioned
bishop to d7 and now just uh queen
side castles and now uh there is one
game in the database from the women's
world blitz championship 2019 where
b5 was played but here magnus goes rook
to c8
and it is as of move 10 that we have a
completely new game
uh so uh what uh what's shion gonna do
he plays knight captures on c5
uh so uh what uh what can black do here
obviously you can reply with b captures
something you don't really want to do it
does make sense to capture towards the
center
but in the knight of sicilian black will
always have the open c file to use for
attacks
you can maybe castle king side the
double rooks and the c file and then
create threats along uh
and the c file towards the white king so
it does make sense to keep the
the file open now one thing you could do
is play bishop captures here which makes
sense uh the bishop will be more useful
in this diagonal also you
for the moment help defending the b7
pawn however magnus goes for rook
captures on c6 he keeps the bishop on d7
which is a bit odd uh but that's why one
of the reasons why we're showing this
game
uh and here you could go for the
prophylactic king to b1
might not be an a bad idea but uh xiong
goes for bishop to h6 right away and
this is the uh well moment where the
magic happens bishop captures an h6
of course so why not queen captures uh
preventing castles for the moment
and now magnus goes for the immediate
rook captures on c3
now rook captures on c3 is not uh
anything weird i mean it's uh it happens
in the night of sicilian all the time
however
in this position it is a bit weird
because you don't have uh
any immediate counter play uh so b
captures on c3 and now queen to a5
and the idea is okay now you ruined the
white spawn structure on the queen side
you're down the exchange but you have
some targets here this is a target this
is a target
so king to d2 defending the c3 pawn
uh and getting the king to safety and
now uh the calm bishop to c6 so not
rushing with with a pawn grab or
anything just bishop to c6
it will come in useful uh when rook to
b1 for example is played and you need to
defend the b7 pawn
uh and here h4 uh xiong is now uh
preparing to start expanding on the king
side with the g4
and so on so here magnus grabs the pawn
with queen captures on a2 and now okay
he's down the exchange but he managed to
grab one pawn
and he already created a past a pawn uh
so
rook the b1 uh and now okay yeah it's
very useful that the bishop is already
on c6 but now queen to a3
queen to a3 probably with the idea of
going queen to c5 followed by queen to
have to check
uh checking the team maybe pick start
picking up material on the king side as
well
so uh xiong brings the queen back we
have queen back to e3
and now queen to a5 by magnus uh
and now g4 so xiung starts expanding on
the king side as well
uh if now of course you you castle then
uh
you could play h5 you could play queen
to g504 queen trade here
a lot of ideas are possible so knight's
the d7
uh not waiting for uh for this move but
also
uh in expectance of f4 magnus wants to
play e5
and or maybe knight will come to c5
which will also be very nice since white
doesn't have a b pawn or a d-pawn to
kick away the knight uh
sorry about that the knight could have a
very nice outpost on c5
so rook to a1 pushing the queen back and
now queen to c5 magnus offers a queen
trade
uh and now uh while you could capture
like i said if this knight
ends up here you don't have uh any pawns
to kick the right away it will be an
excellent outpost for the knight
so instead xiang pushes f4 he starts his
expansion on the king side and now
e5 and now okay if pawn captures then
the knight can also find
a very nice outpost for itself on e5
uh and here uh shiong decides to trade
queens he is up the exchange
so he's very happy with this uh we have
queen captures d
captures and now rook h to f1 uh
preparing to open up the file but not
just yet we have king to e7 and now rook
to a5
rook to a5 with the idea uh you cannot
move the knight
since the c pawn is under attack you
cannot defend it with b6 since you lose
the a6 pawn
and also there's just the threat of
capturous captures and of course
captures on c5 once
the knight is overloaded so here magnus
has to decide whether he wants to defend
with f6
uh here you would get uh something like
f5 g capture c
captures and then uh in order to prevent
the g5 you could play something like
h6 and uh it's still it's
uh it's a playable position it's a weird
position but they're definitely a
playable one
where white should white should always
be better however
it's very hard for the rooks to find uh
any any activity
probably a you want to uh activate them
along the d
file as it's the only open file on the
board however uh then you allow black to
start expanding on the queen side with
uh
b5 a5 a5 a4 and so on so instead after
this rook to a5 idea magnus decides to
give up
um the c5 pawn however he will also
create a weakness on the king side so he
plays h6
and xiong goes for it with f captures on
e5
magnus captures with the knight now that
f4 has been played g4 has been weakened
rook captures on c5 and knight captures
on g4
and now uh e5 and we get
another very very cool position very
active position where
the rooks are still not easy to
coordinate but at least now you have the
semi-open f file to use for your rook so
magnus goes rook to d8 he shifts the
rook to the
only open open file on the board and now
rook to
f4 attacking the knight but also
preparing rook to d4
you kind of want to undouble your pawns
if at all possible
so we have h5 magnus defends it and now
rook to d4
going for this trade and now if you do
this then white is pretty much just
winning you've uh
fixed his only weakness he's going to
play a c4
that's a weird arrow c4 d5 and that's
just winning for white
so here we have rook to e8 magnus of
course cannot afford this trade
and now uh xiong finds a very nice pawn
grab bishop captures an a6 point is that
if you capture then rook captures on c6
you've pretty much uh fully activated
your rooks and
let's say knight captures an e5 you grab
the phone back rook e4 attacks the
knight king f8
and you get to this position uh where
well uh white will of course grab the a6
pawn and then
you get to this position uh where why
where the material is
equal regarding pawns of course white is
still up the exchange but it's very hard
uh for example knight f3 check king will
move let's say king e3
you're gonna pick up the h4 pawn now
white will be up upon and if a trade
happens you will have a rook and the
knight
but black will have three connected pass
pawns against uh
white's two pawns which are doubled on
the c file but
white of course is still better so
instead
after bishop captures an a6 magnus
doesn't go for this he just plays king
to f8
gets the king to safety and now uh
bishop to b5
uh an interesting idea uh there
is the engine line of course there is
always the engine line and
i will mention it at some point but here
it's just weird for example rook to b4
uh now threatens to capture the b7 pawn
of course
we already said that this is good for
white so rook to e7 defending and now
e6 but this is just something you don't
consider if you're a human
uh point is that now uh if the rook
captures you can pick up the b7 pawn so
you
black will have to capture this way and
uh now black's
pawns will be much more vulnerable as uh
well there's nothing that a rook likes
more than an isolated pawn
so here instead after king to f8 this is
a this is a pretty wild plan of course
that we just mentioned but
xion goes for bishop to b5 right away
now magnus captures the e5 pawn
and now it it makes sense now that you
see it because
you're gonna lose the e5 pawn either way
so why not mess up uh
black spawn structure in doing so but
okay knight captures on e5 and now
bishop captures on c6 we have b captures
on c6 and now
rook to e4 with a double attack on the
knight but now magnus plays
f6 and this is definitely one of those
situations where it is okay
to play f6 especially if you look at it
now as long as
this pawn is defending the knight and
this knight defending the pawn here
uh white's rooks are are just useless
there's
no there's no good way to to make use of
them
this is just an unpenetrable barrier so
uh we have king to a3 and now king to f7
magnus also brings his king into the
game king to f4
and now rook to a8 and now if you don't
want uh
for magnus to start creating some
threats
along the back rank there's a there are
there are a lot of
weaknesses here uh you go for rook
captures on e5 since you realize that
the knight is just too powerful here you
just give it up
give up your exchange to reduce the
pressure on the position
so rook captures on e5 with f captures
on e5 with
check king captures on e5 and now rook
to e8 with
check king to f4 and now rook to e6
defending and now
after 38 moves the material on the board
is equal
we have c4 by xiong and now comes rook
to f6
check we have king to e4 and now king to
g7
we have rook to e5 not much you can do
in
position like this and now rook to f1 by
magnus
uh with king to d4 shion now tries to
bring the king over to c5 to eliminate
this pawn
however uh rook to f4 with check and now
xiung has to make a decision whether to
go back go forth
uh allow the capture on h4 or to block
with the rook
and while doing so to defend the pawn
here so
uh the the the point is you should go
king to c3
and just uh just keep an eye
on everything guard the two points with
the king then your rook can pick up this
pawn
and you can play this end game and try
to win the race well you're probably not
going to succeed in winning but you
you probably will be able to draw
however uh xiang played rook the e4 here
he decided to defend
while also guarding the pawn uh but
this now just doesn't work because
magnus captures it with
check we have king captures and now king
to f6
and now of course xion goes for the
opposition king to f4
but now feel free to pause the video and
try to find the winning move
uh for magnus here while i give you a
couple of seconds as it's a very very
exciting uh structure
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on being
an excellent student of the end game and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show uh
it's c5 uh c5 it's very important
c5 followed by g5 not the other way
around the problem with starting with
the g5 check
is that after h captures and king to g6
uh
white can actually play c5 and
completely limit your options here you
you will not have any
any good moves your king cannot really
stay stay here so you'd have to play
something like this and after this
you're going to play this captures
captures and now we finally
get an opposition so here you will not
be winning as the opposition is
uh well it always exists so there is no
win here
however if you found c5 then black wins
and the point is next of course the c3
uh
white doesn't want to move the king
first and now of course g5 with
check with h captures on g5 and now king
to g6
and it was in this position on move uh
47 that jeffrey chiung resigned to the
game and the game nine goes to magnus
here white resigns as there is nothing
more to be done here
uh white is unable to complete the
opposition uh so
uh for example uh we could we could play
it out a little bit let's take him to g3
king capture sun g5 and now uh for those
of you who are new to the channel or new
to chess in general uh if you don't know
what the opposition
is uh you you should definitely google
it and
there there are a lot of uh material on
on the internet about about it you can
learn about it and it will help you
a great deal in your own endgame so here
of course uh
let's say king to f3 you have to play
something but now just came to f5 white
now has to deal with this pawn
and uh black will use the the remaining
time
uh to go after the queen side pawn so
let's say king e3 you're gonna go
h4 so now white has to deal with the
pass pawn king of three h3
uh king to g3 now king e4 and now after
this
you finally gobble up the pawns king g3
king captures you're gonna go king of
three captures here king e2 but now king
to c2
you of course don't allow the the white
king to uh
touch touch the c file uh and now uh
after a few more moves you're just gonna
push your pawn here you're gonna push it
here
here let's say king b2 and now the pawn
queens and it's
game over so uh shing of course knows
this and after king to g6 he resigned
the game
so what's very what's very impressive
and what's
great about this game is that after
carlson's rook captures on c3 idea
uh pretty much in the in the opening uh
the engine
uh only favors white uh uh the engine
says it's uh not
really uh not a very impressive uh
let me just uh go back here
yeah uh the engine doesn't doesn't
really enjoy this
but uh when a human plays it of course
it is much harder to
uh to coordinate everything but xiang
was better he was better for the entire
game
and then at some point uh the knight
was just too powerful uh so the knight
was able to control both rooks and in
the end xiuong
was forced to give up one of the rooks
for the night
but yeah uh that's the game i do hope
you enjoyed it like i said i haven't
been uh
following uh the clutch in uh
international
uh in great detail but if you have a
favorite game of your own do use hashtag
suggestions suggest your game
i'm gonna check it out and we'll
probably make a video on it from
especially if it's from some of the
other matches so yeah
i would like to thank vladimir niche
fernando james stefano minguzzi uh dk
benjamin and heron nicasso for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage
of the clutch international checking up
on your wonderful
suggestions uh continuing the morphe
saga and whatever else happens in the
chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day